i want to go back because we're talking
about economics i want to go back to
something i've been telling you about
for a decade at this point in time
there are now more
sort of mainstream
media outlets
taking this topic seriously if you go
back a really long time
certainly 50 years you can go back 80.
it starts to become less useful if you
go beyond when the party's switched but
if you go back 50 years when you have a
democratic president in the white house
job growth does better
people's income and income growth does
better and gdp growth does better now as
always there is no one there are no two
or three metrics which tell you
everything you need to know about how an
economy is doing you could say but we
need to look at wages labor
participation inflation all these
different things consumer confidence
sure
but jobs income and gdp all taken
together are well accepted metrics of
how an economy is doing
and they all do better on average when
the president is a democrat i am
thrilled and we're linking to this
article that newsweek is finally talking
about this they write nearly all major
u.s economic indicators including income
productivity stock prices jobs and
domestic product
show growth under democratic presidents
compared to when republicans are in the
white house i'm not going to give you
all the data again because we've given
it to you so many times if you had the
choice going back between saying do i
want to be in the job market when
there's a democrat in the white house or
a republican statistically you would
have been better off when there's a
democrat in the white house if you had
said i'm going to invest in the s p 500
when there's a democrat in the white
house or a republican if you could pick
only the years that one or the other is
in the white house
your investment return would be
dramatically better if you had invested
only in the democratic years now
remember that stocks in general tend to
go up so you would have done okay in
either case but you would have done
better
when there was a democratic president in
the white house the new york times
released an analysis on this and the
economy does better when democrats are
president by every single metric now
whenever this is presented whenever this
fact is presented and it is a fact
you might not like it you might want to
explain it away but it is a fact we hear
many arguments against
one of the arguments we hear is
david you're looking at the wrong thing
those
metrics did better
because it was a republican-controlled
house or a republican-controlled senate
or both
and the answer is
no there is no clear partisan pattern
when you look at control of the house
and control of the senate
other than it sometimes matches
what is going on in the oval office
that's not a good argument
next argument that's often made is
democrats just get lucky you know what
happens
republicans have these recessions
and they fix them and then they leave
office and then in comes a democratic
president and they get all the credit
for what a republican did and there's
two answers to that the first answer to
that is okay
let's pretend that what you're saying is
true
let's give the first six months of any
one president's economic growth
to the last guy so in other words what
that would mean is barack obama's first
six months will give to george w bush
give george w bush a little bit of the
credit for the obama recovery
it still favors democrats so even if you
kind of put in place a six-month grace
period the numbers still don't look much
better for republicans but maybe the
most important thing about this is
if it's true that democrats are coming
in and experiencing economic recoveries
when they're in the white house
why are there so many republican
recessions that have to be fixed during
democratic administration so the
analysis is extraordinarily clear it's a
well-known phenomenon and yet this is
why you know we we opened the show today
by saying
economic reality
political reality
you might have an economic reality
politically it doesn't exist unless
people believe it and much the same way
there is this it's really a meme at this
point it's a self it almost spreads
virally there's this idea
that republicans are better stewards of
the economy
there are no
statistical
uh uh
sets of data
that you can point to
in which that is the case
let me know via twitter you can find me
at d pacman
why does this talking point about
republicans being good for the economy
persist so strongly because it does find
me on twitter let me know also just a
quick reminder tuesday april 19th
6 p.m eastern is the next david pakman
show town hall it will be streaming live
on pacman live
all are welcome
uh that's april 19th 6 p.m looking
forward to seeing and hearing from many
of you